so we're gonna start off today thank you
very much for the unusually purse
introduction and thanks for yeah thanks
for okay sure so so you can see there's
some clouds here clouds out there so I'm
very happy that I can feel it like at
home in Edinburgh today this is probably
the first or second day in a couple
months we've been like this is very nice
so I'll be talking about popcorn sent
methods so this is how I view these
things you try to get to the top of a
hill you're maximizing or minimizing and
it's just difficult because you get this
big data baggage with you so most of
this work is John work with Martin Tkach
who is over there and on the job market
at the same time so there you go and
some of this stuff is also with some
other quarters such as olive airfare
coke aveline beer ow not disabled and so
on so we have some coats Hydra ac/dc
you'll see these logos around later on
alright so first of all I could think
California is expensive so this is my
actual it's my actual taxi receipt from
that in bra I didn't pay it okay alright
so how many of you know what Korda
descent is sure alright good so so there
you go this big data optimization with
coordinate coordinate descent so this is
what you want to want to do so you want
to find the minimizer of a function I'll
explain everything in the serial case
not nopales and right now in a 2d
setting so you want to get down there
now this is what you do if you randomize
so you flip a coin and then the coin
says you should go east or west now of
course you don't want to go uphill so
you go that direction which is down the
hill then you go and somehow you decide
on this step size in the case of a
quadratic you actually exactly minimize
the quadratic
if this thing is not quadratic you may
be minimize some kind of quadratic over
approximation of this or something like
this or proximal step etc so now you go
there why would you do this why would
you randomize well there's clearly
better direction you can go that way but
it's just in huge dimensions difficult
to find that direction it may involve
the inversion of a matrix or the kind of
stuff or maybe full matrix vector
operations what you want to do you want
to simplify thanks randomized so things
are easy it's very silly decision but
very quick and usually this step will
you know if you have a matrix let's say
in the least square setting ax minus B
norm squared this step will just take as
many additions and multiplications if
you're non zeros in a in a column of a
matrix so if you have a sparse matrix is
just very easy sometimes it's just all
one their problem is with just four
multiplications four additions so you
can do billions of these steps so
there's a trade-off you do very very
cheap stuff but you can you can do many
of them so now I think I click this
again so you go up write again minimize
that function then you flip the coin
again you go there and you just just
just repeat in the 2d setting doesn't
really make sense and specially if you
have a quadratic to go in the same
direction twice because there be no
decrease but in more dimensions and
specially this function is not quadratic
it would make sense alright so then you
just repeat and you can see kind of
zigzag to the solution right so this is
how it works this is it all right so
it's solved now you can flip these coins
in a biased way if you want but
everything I'll be talking about today
is this unbiased setting so equal
probabilities so there's some reason to
work where you can show that if these
probably's are biased in some smart ways
this thing can be actually much faster
in theory and I will not be talking
about this but I'll be talking about
paralyzing this thing
sir could you repeat it was exactly
which is alternating so in my example
we're just alternating but this is - no
it's not supposed to be alternating you
just you just flip it but in this in a
2d setting it just doesn't make sense to
go twice in the same direction and
especially if you have a quadratic if
you have a quadratic you just minimize
in the direction you go again
there's there's no gain yeah all right
so so so in a nutshell this is what's
going on if you have randomized
coordinates sent with uniform
probabilities in n dimensions this is
how many iterations this thing would
tick tick and think of these iterations
in this part setting is something very
cheap maybe just all one iterations okay
so it's n times some function of epsilon
where this epsilon can be either this or
dead depending on whether the problem is
easy or hard and and so on so you have a
strongly convex function you get linear
convergence or some people called it
exponential whatever you want to call it
log 1 over epsilon even is something
smooth or simple on smooth such as lasso
so you have just l1 regular as you give
1 over epsilon Y or something difficult
you would get 1 over epsilon squared
right but now what I want to say I don't
care about this I don't care about the
rate it's not that I really don't care
but I want to paralyze this thing so
that I really care about is this n I
want to push this off to huge dimensions
N and I do not want dependence on n like
this I want something better than there
ok so that's the goal now so this is
what you you would ideally want so this
is what you have in the serial setting
is what you would want in the pal
setting when you have Towe processors
right so maybe tau is n if tau is n if
you have as many process of course you
don't have this many processors as
there's variables but if tau is n then
you just divide by top so it kind of
ideal inner speed-up okay now one thing
I should say is that these coordinates
don't have to be really coordinate these
can be blocks of coordinates so if you
think working with one cordon at a time
is not good enough you can just
partition the
variables or the coordinates into blocks
and think of these as coordinates but
I'll be talking about coordinates only
everything transfers directly to that
general block setting so we'll do we
actually get we get something like this
alright so you get almost this but
there's this beta around and this beta
can be small or large and in some
settings you just it just has to be
large in some settings it will be small
so sometimes the the take-home message
from this sometimes paralyzation
will just not work okay corner descent
is is a sequential algorithm if you
paralyze it sometimes it will just not
work so you have to be very careful
looking for these examples where does
work fortunately in many big data
applications does work because there's
lots of sparsity I'll explain them later
on okay so so this is whether you would
want something very small good
so how not to paralyze coordinates say
so so how about the following idea so
you do the same thing as before but just
for all coordinates right so you
minimize exactly let's say the quadratic
in one direction exactly in the other
maybe in a randomly chosen subset of
coordinates maybe in all of them depends
how many four sensors you have sometimes
it's not a good idea to do everything
because you may have billions and
billions of of coordinates and it just
doesn't make sense to have a such a
heavy step it makes sense to maybe do
100,000 in one iteration and then maybe
hundred thousand again this is exactly
why coordinates and algorithms we're
device yeah so the question for the
online audience is that I didn't say
anything about the objective evaluation
and how cheap or expensive that that was
so the thing is that coordinates and
algorithms you don't really want to
evaluate the objective okay and a huge
dimensional setting what you want to do
you want to work with partial
derivatives and you maintain these
derivatives so I will never evaluate the
objective at all and of course
it depends on the function whether this
is difficult or easy now I'll talk about
a little bit later on but largely I
would just ignore this question in this
talk because I just don't have that
enough time for that but in many
settings one iteration would be think of
it all one amount of work okay so that's
that's that's one you would want to
apply for it at the same alright so you
do more all of these and add them up
okay so here is a carefully constructed
simple to the example so you have this
is 0 0 this is 1 1 function value is 1
over here function value is 1 over there
ok it's very simple function here in the
middle you have the optimal set function
value 0 now you start at the origin and
you say all right you'll be good to move
in this direction right so you move in
that direction you actually solve the
problem with one coordinate right but
now you want to be smart so you say oh
I'll be smarter I do two at a time right
and I add these up this is what happens
so not very smart right parallelization
doesn't help you at all because then you
go there you repeat
oops you're back it's not always good to
be back ok it's not always good to be
back so this was a bad example right so
this doesn't work partition here it's
very simple to do thing now you think ok
now I know what I should do
of course so so maybe if I want to
paralyze I should actually average all
right now let's ignore the fact that
actually we're just one coordinate
you've solved the problem because this
is simple 2d thing ok so I'll just
average things out well great but then
you look at this example right so you
have a perfectly separable quadratic
just x1 squared plus x2 squared all
right you do the same thing you want to
get to the middle now this is what you
do with one coordinate is what you do
with a other corner now you Everage is
where you go but you should have added
this up right if you edit these things
up you solved in one step because these
are just two completely independent
problems so you can solve one you can
solve the other and these things have
been everything is good
but you don't know you think okay
everything is the stuff to do so you
repeat and you can see it will take a
lot of time to get to the middle alright
so so now you cannot add things up
averaging doesn't work so we should do
alright so and so on so so let's look at
exactly the same example but with n
dimensions so if you have n dimensions
you start at the origin the function
value is n at the origin and after K
iterations you can just easily you know
write down this what happens so if you
want this to be less than equal to
epsilon then you need this many
iterations and it soundly depends on n
literally so it grows with dimension and
if n is huge is exactly what you want to
avoid okay so this is bad this is what
we really wanted so this actually means
if tau is essentially n here because you
do end things at the same time if tau
processors taos coordinates at the same
time so so these things cancel so beta
is n it's bet that's the best thing you
want you don't you want beta to be to be
small not large right so the whole fog
is about when this beta can be small so
somehow there's something to do with
maybe separate bility if the problem was
separable beta can be set to 1 you add
things up if it's not beta will be large
and that's precisely what's going on and
and there's some some deeper truth to
that as well so so this is the algorithm
in the smooth case and now for
simplicity you'll see later on how that
generalizes a little bit so you have
current iterate next it turret you sum
all of these updates up and beta one
there's the summation beta n is
averaging and what you want is beta
somehow close to 1 maybe not one maybe
all 1 or something like this but
certainly not Han and it's bad ok say
any questions at this point
ok
yeah you'll see later on you'll see
later so here is just building the
intuition okay yeah yes it's not clear
at this point but you can see that this
beta is averaging if it's n and it's one
of your summation so at least at least
you know that okay all right so so now
the optimization problems we want to
look at so you can apply core in this
and it turns out to non convex problems
you can apply them to nonlinear problems
and so on I'll just focus on convex
problems because that's that's the area
I work in and I focus on minimization of
a regularized loss so you have one term
another term both are convex and this
can be smooth or non smooth and this can
be smooth as well as well but it's
simple so this is a regular such as l1
and so on so forth
all right so here are some examples for
the regularizer so the analysis works
whenever this regularizer is separable
in these coordinates or in blocks if you
have locks so for instance if it's 0 of
course it's separable or you can have
waited and one more as in lhasa right or
you can have both constraints as an SVM
dual you can have weighted l 2-norm and
so on so separable things work well for
the for the theory now what about the
loss functions you can all kinds of loss
functions are some examples only how
later tell you about the general
structure because of course you don't
want to analyze this well maybe you do
so you don't want to analyze this for
this function then for that function and
so you'd like to have a general theory
which works for a class of functions of
course the general theory will then be
weaker so if you want to specialize get
something more out of it then go ahead
and do that and get better results but
it's good to also have this general
understanding so you can see that some
of these things are smooth and some are
non smooth so L 1 is not smooth infinity
is non smooth this is actually smoothing
of a non smooth function so these things
are smooth and should behave Lipschitz
gradient and so on right so so you have
all kinds of losses and you can see
exponential laws you can see that
actually part of a version of a
coordinate sent applied to this
something like power other boost
all right then you can have linear
programming if you do this you could
have all kinds of other things okay so
now these are the three general models
and I'll be only talking about two of
those and all these functions belong to
one of these models and you can analyze
them separately
so one model is the following smooth
partially separable functions so
function is partially separable if it
can be written as a sum of functions
each of which depends only on few
variables of the decision vector alright
so you have maybe billion variables
billion coordinates billion features
it's all the same thing
and some of some of such functions each
of them depends maybe on ten thirty
hundred thousand but not billion and you
get this because you have sparse graphs
you have you know do in big data setting
many times this happens every example
depends on only a few features and
you're there all right okay now what's
what a smoothness mean this is just a
little generalization or refinement
actually of the concept of Lipschitz
continuity of the gradient since
coordinate descent methods work by
looking in the chord and directions you
want to have Lipschitz constants for
every coordinate direction and you get
finer information because Lipschitz
constant for the gradient of the entire
function might be something very large
there's one thing and the other thing is
it may be just hard to compute if you
have a billion by billion matrix
Lipschitz constant might be some kind of
largest eigenvalue of the thing so maybe
it's better to work with with these
little Lipschitz constant alright and
you can already feel that if this Omega
the degree of partial separable it is a
one there was the example with a
circular region that means it's
separable that should be fine the beta
should be small it should be actually
one right
if this Omega is maybe large beta would
be large that's exactly what what's
going on so this Omega will find it will
tell you what the beta is if Omega is
small beta will be small if you'll make
a large beta will be large and you can
see I'm not assuming anything else this
is all I'm assuming so just smoothness
and in this structure and you already
have some understanding when this thing
will work or not of course the results
that you get will
be weaker than if you specialized
resolvers a special function so maybe
you can replace this Omega by something
that is smaller than Omega and there'll
be maybe it's some I can build or
something like this but it's already
giving you some information all right
now I will not talk about this today but
is another recent work where you have
non-smooth max type functions these are
functions those of you who know nestor
of smoothing this is exactly what nestor
works with so this is maximum of a bunch
of linear functions over some infinite
index set so it will be a convex
function so it looks like this right you
have a bunch of linear functions and you
take a maximum of those these are linear
in X so you have a convex function but
you have this very special
representation of the convex function in
this kind of subtle form formally and
you have some matrix a around and so on
G will be convex function Q will be
convex set a some kind of matrix and so
on so here you can define something like
the degree of partial separable it even
though it's not degree of partial
separable ad but it's some kind some
some other measure of separable ad so is
the maximum number of non-zeros in the
row of the matrix and many times in big
data applications this will be much
smaller than the number of columns and
if that is the case beta will be small
coordinates and methods paralyzed well
if it's large they will not paralyse
well okay so that's that's the idea okay
now the third one which I'll talk about
is functions with by bounded Hessian so
these were for instance constant in the
shotgun this shotgun in the shotgun
paper or in the Hydra paper so these are
functions which kind of look like this
you have global quadratic over
approximation with the constant Hessian
everywhere doesn't mean that the
original function is twice
differentiable it just says you know
this is what's going on right there's
just this this is over approximation all
right so now you can set L to be the
diagonal of a TA and if you do this
thing you essentially make sure that the
diagonal is 1 and you take the largest
eigen value of that matrix and the point
is if this Sigma is small this Sigma
will be at least 1 if
it's one it's then this stuff is
perfectly paralyzing if it's large
current assignments are not well
paralyzing right so all of these
quantities Omega Omega and Sigma they
are just they're telling you where the
coordinates and methods will be
paralyzing boring on any questions okay
good yeah exactly
so that then what it means is that maybe
it doesn't make sense to use more
processors maybe you should go for a
look for a different algorithm or maybe
it tells you that you know this thing
works with for your processors all right
so now the general theory so the general
theory you've seen this already before
looks like this but there's one change
to you so this is character new turret
and so on but now I have this random set
as head so that that's that's the change
so now I'm saying I'm not going to
paralyze everything it doesn't make
sense always to update all the
coordinates in one iteration because
then you have something like a gradient
algorithm and coordinates and algorithms
can be much much better than green alga
resizer because they don't use then
update all coordinates so we have this
set as head and this set as head can
have cardinality one if it is currently
one you have just serial coordinates and
if it's cardinality n you update
everything and you can choose it as any
random subset of the set of coordinates
okay
so it also what it buys you is that you
have this general theory which spans
scored and ascended zero setting to
cornice and to the power setting it also
makes it possible for you to fine-tune
the probabilities to these different
sets and so on
all right so now here is a key concept
in the analysis of all these algorithms
so it's the Equality expected sample
over approximation so we say that
function f that means beta W ESO with
respect to a uniform sampling as held by
uniform I mean the probability that any
given coordinate is picked by as head is
equal for all for all coordinates it's
possible to define a different
ESO for non-uniform probabilities I will
not work
that today if this inequality holds
right so so let's look at this in a
quickie inequality which tells you a lot
what what does it tell you a lot because
I didn't tell you how you pick as head
at all right now
I didn't tell you how you do the updates
well in the quadratic setting you know
you just exactly minimize but it's this
inequality will tell you what to do so
now imagine you have picked your
favorite as head maybe one coordinate
with probably 1 over N or 2 coordinates
with some probability and and so on you
just pick your favorite as head assign
probabilities to subsets off of the set
of coordinates now you look at this
inequality and what do you want to do
you want to minimize the right hand side
in H and that's your update now why well
you know look at this this thing tells
you what is the function value at the
next iterate right if x is your current
a threat this is the function value at
the next iterate right but the function
value next it o is a random variable
because you're randomly picking these
coordinates so how do you move right so
you want to move the power constant
method says you want to move in such a
way to minimize the expected function
value at the next a threat okay that's
what it says
so ideally what you would want to do you
want to minimize the left hand side in H
forgiven as head but that's just
intractable you cannot do it it's
difficult so instead what you say you
over approximate this by a quadratic and
then you minimize that but it buys you
three things at the same time so this
was not minimizing but at the same time
this thing actually is minimizing
but it's also minimizing power because
it's separable image that's why I've
called the expected separable verb proxy
which is separable in h right because
this quadratic is separable quadratic is
just diagonal matrix there right and
moreover you can just minimize for those
coordinates that you're going to update
so you don't minimize for all corners
and throw everything out and keep just
what is in s hat all right so so it by Z
all these things and that's the
algorithm so you somehow come up with
this ESO
once you have the ESO for the function
and as head which means you have these
parameters beta and W which which are
actually parameters for your method then
you minimize this right-hand side and
that's your next x-ray okay so this is
how it's going to look like in this case
all right so if you minimize this just
set the derivative equal to zero is
convex quadratic this is what you get so
you go in these coordinate directions
you take partial derivatives step size
is 100 WI but they're kind of either
averaged or sum up or something like
that right and these w's will be as
you'll see
maybe these Lipschitz constant Li or
something else depends on the model you
work with and this w will be either 1 or
n or something in between depending on
whether the function is may be sampled
or not nice or bad
ok and of course if you have this non
smooth regularizer then this thing will
look a little bit different there be
this proximal term but let's you know
shuffle that away all right so now here
is one convergence result so if this F
has had satisfied this ESO for beta and
W now I didn't tell you how to compute
beta and W and if you don't obey tyw you
cannot run the method I'll tell you
later on how to compute beta and W but
if you have somehow magically have
computed beta and W then you immediately
have a convergence result and it tells
you that it takes beta times n divided
by this and this is essentially tau
right because this is the average number
of updates you do in one iteration I
didn't tell you that s head has to pick
always a constant number of coordinates
maybe in one iteration you update v in
another iteration update 30 and so on
maybe what you have is unreliable
processors you give them work on only
some of them give you updates so your
work with ran the number of updates at
every iteration this analysis captures
them ok so this is exactly what we want
and this is that X I epsilon which we
don't care about ok and we care about
this one 1 beta up to be small then with
high probability probably always 1 minus
Rho Rho is inside logarithm so it's ok
you have approximately solved your
problem ok
so this is the result so row if row can
be small it's fine epsilon can be small
well this is kind of maybe difficult but
if you have a if you have a strongly
convex setting then the epsilon is in
the low garden and it's not you know
elsewhere so it looks like this then
it's a little bit different because you
have these strong convexity constants of
this regularizer and the loss and they
can improve things so in particularly if
this is if this is large then the effect
of beta beta will be kind of subdued
okay all right so this kind of generic
theory now you have to come up with this
beta and w so you can run the algorithm
so any questions at this point all right
good so now I'll tell you how to compute
this beta and W for for this model one
the model one was partially separable
smooth functions and then you know
exactly what to do all right
so first of all I didn't tell you so far
about this random sampling so here's one
the simplest one there's the one we have
worked with in the beginning in the 2d
setting so this is probably the low
uniform cereal with probably one over n
take one coordinate so probably one over
N pick that I want probably one over and
pick that one and so on so you do this
alright cereal uniform one possibility
another possibility
pick three at a time or certain number
at a time uniformly at random so these
three these three B's 3 and so on so you
have to pick 3 so as a subset but you
can also you can also let if you think
of these things as processors you can
let each of them decide whether they're
picked or not then you have something
which we call double uniform so they can
be also analyzed so here is double
uniform so this is the following thing
so you have imagine that you decide that
you're going to update one coordinate
with probably q1 you're going to update
two coordinates we probably q2 three
coordinates we probably q3 and you
decide on this problem in law so then
you flip a coin and say alright I'm
updating one at this iteration okay and
then you pick uniformly at random which
one you update
another iteration you decide you're
going to update three with probably q3
and then you decide okay which three
uniformly at random you pick three okay
then it turns out next con slip tells
you should update two and then uniformly
randomly pick the two you're going to
update so this we call double uniform
because it's uniform in two ways but you
know okay so this is the probably law
and again you can think of this as s
maybe unreliable processors and so on
which give you answer or not etc so okay
with probably q5 you update everything
okay all right so this is a double
uniform this the most general sampling
so the idea what we came up with this
because this is the most general
sampling which gives you small beta so
there's the take-home message so the
convergence guarantee will depend on the
sampling not just on the function right
because I told you that this ESO depends
on the function and the way you
randomize so if you randomize badly
maybe you just screw things up right if
the function is bad you know you get a
better result but but you can come up
with good samplings which give you good
results may be in for bet functions and
this double uniform one is the more
general one we have for which we can
tell you that beta is good so that's why
we have it there otherwise just think
about the style uniform we you pick same
number of coordinates in one iteration
and this is the this is the result which
tells you what beta and W should be like
because this is this was a stuff that I
didn't tell you before so if you have
this smooth partially separable function
so this T is Martin over there in the
audience so you have these Lipschitz
constants in each coordinate direction
and there's a sum of functions each of
which depends on at most Omega
coordinates features variables okay so
that's the setting then if you have
double uniform sampling that was the
last one the most general one then you
have this ESO is just definition of the
ear so but you now have formulas for
beta and W and these are
this is not something you have to
compute and you just plug it in and you
have it so in particular this w i's are
just this lis and in many situations is
LRS come from free if you have a least
squares problem this ll eyes are the
squared norms of the columns of the
matrix so you just get there yeah job no
can be can't be so Sam yes but
individual ones can't be so individual
ones are smaller than than the Big L
that's that's true yes but the the bound
actually depends on the average of the
Allies not on the Sun okay so that
that's what's going to be in the result
you get average of these allies not the
some of these are wise if it is with
unit for probability so it's better the
reason why you get it with average is
because I mean you can just look here
and see that you divide by the sum take
the sum in front of it and you get
actually average okay all right all
right so these are the W is what is beta
so let's just analyze this right what is
beta it's one plus so one is the good
thing you don't want the plus thing
right one would be perfect that means
you were adding things up and everything
is great but not everything is great so
you have something that have add to this
one what is it well look at this and for
now think that norm cardinality of s
head is just tau you always update tau
coordinates in that case this is tau
square divided by tau to just stop so
this is tau minus one so for instance if
you update just one coordinate at a time
then this is zero so this plus is not
there and beta is one that's precisely
what were saying before right so if you
just want current beta is one everything
is good
if this tau is n
then this thing cancels out with this
and you have Omega minus one plus one so
this is Omega
so beta is equal to Omega if you use as
many processors as you have coordinates
of course you never do that unless you
have small problem but that tells you
that beta can be at most Omega which is
exactly what you want because there's a
degree of partial separable if that is
small everything is fine its small its
oh one let's say right if each example
depends on at most 10,000 features on
the guy's ten thousand but not 10
trillion what is the number of features
right something like that all right so
that's it all right so this is this is
the result okay so now you can see this
is there this is there and now beta is
small if only guys small everything is
good great
so now how does how does it look like so
you could actually plot this and you can
plot what the speed-up will be compared
to the setting in which you update only
one coordinate at a time okay so if you
update only one cordon at a time you get
certain constant in front of the
complexity the complexity factor if how
is not one you get another one you can
take ratio of these things and this is
what the speed-up is so if omega minus 1
divided by n minus 1 is large that means
this thing is not separable you know
it's not well separable so this is the
bed bed message but that kind of a
region domain for peril constant
algorithms but it turns out the magic
bigger that is here were only few
variables matter in each example that
means that you get very good speed up so
if you have 16 processors the speed-up
is 16 and then it goes down like this it
goes down like 1 over 1 over R right so
you really live here in much of sparse
optimization in the Big Data setting
which means you get almost linear
speed-up okay now these are theoretical
curves for this very general setting
with partial separable leti these curves
look much better
if you analyze it for a special problem
class where you have more information so
if you have information about some icon
values this be much better but this
gives you the generic bound for
everything good now this theory looks
fine of course but how tight is this
right so so this is theory just
different way of writing down the speed
up number of processors one ten hundred
thousand speed-up ten hundred this is
thousand coordinates small dimension so
this Omega equals five means it's pretty
separable right it's pretty sad oh my
god it was five at most five non-zeros
any drawn matrix if you have a least
squares problem this means you get
almost almost linear speed-up if Omega
is hundred right which means ten percent
of these things in each in each row of
your matrix are nonzero then it makes
sense to maybe use hundred processors
but not much more you don't get any more
speed up with that but this is this is
necessary somehow because this is what
we get with computations okay so look at
this this is theory this is practice so
further you know remaining 20 bits
I'll just keep doing this okay all right
so this is theory this is practice but
this is a cooked up example which is
tight okay so so it's not that bad this
is an example when you have a least
squares problem where in each row of the
matrix you have exactly Omega non zeros
and all of them are equal in different
rows there may be of different magnitude
it's a very special cooktop example and
then we get exactly what the theory says
and with respect to the speed-up of
course in practice you don't get these
bad problems right so this thing can be
much better but this theory in some
sense tight all right so now experiment
with a 1 billion by 2 billion last
problem so optimization with big data
for those I mean I I've you know many of
you gave very nice nice talks on
optimization big data and you may be
a lot of time in the lab coding things
up and so on so if this is a little bit
of consolation to get a lot of exercise
extreme exercise by doing this okay so
it's really climbing what do you do
alright so so here you have one core to
course up to 24 course we do it on one
note only billion by two billion matrix
very sparse Omega very small and you run
this and you're not you count the number
of coordinate updates essentially right
and you see that after about 35 times
billion cordoned updates 35 billion
current updates all of these algorithms
independent whether you update the one
coordinate at a time or 24 coordinates
at a time
all of them solve the problem and by
solve I mean solve I mean this is solved
you know this is more than 30 degrees of
magnitude so this thing is solved to
death okay so there's a official you
know optimization term so 10 to the 20
10 to the minus 10 in machine learning
you never want to do this of course that
means that you can stop much much much
much sooner okay all right so now of
course if we do 24 at a time you do that
about 24 times faster and this is what
it will it tells you in terms of number
of iterations this takes much fewer
iterations right if you have 24 at a
time
in terms of wall time is the same thing
as iterations these iterations are very
predictable they're very light all right
so this is wall time so you actually get
speed up about 20 if you have 24
processors of 21 or something like this
okay now this is an artificial problem
we have results for real problems as
well this is artificial promise so that
we actually know what the solution is
exactly there's the only way how we can
say that we sold it to the to debt
akhira see we cook up the problem using
duality
yes so this was uniform this was uniform
yeah
so this is artificial problem this thing
scares up to real problems as well but
we want it to really see whether whether
this works whether you can solve it too
high high high accuracy all right so now
a distributed version of this and let me
let me check how am I going doing well
all right so we call this thing Hydra
and this how it works
so here we come up with different
sampling the sampling is not serial
uniform what I talk about is not just
our unit for at our uniform tan eyes
it's not this w is different one we call
it let's say this should be Thomas okay
so this is what's going on if you have a
number of notes and you want to run a
purl cornice and algorithm this how will
you choose the coordinates so that's the
question how will you choose the
coordinates right so let's say you want
to use town light sampling you choose
you're going to update 10,000
coordinates or 10 million coordinates in
one iteration which nodes will be doing
the updates well if you say you want to
have all the nodes have equal load then
issue you should make sure that they get
some work to do but if each node is
allowed to work on all coordinates you
have to shift a lot of data around okay
so instead what you do you partition the
data in such a way that machine one only
takes care of these coordinates and no
other coordinates and with those
coordinates you send all the data
related to those coordinates to the
machine and and the data will be there
okay so data will be distributed in that
fashion machine to will own these and so
on so you create part we partition the
data column wise if you have at least
question always think of this
least-squares : wise your partition so
it's different from the table from
yesterday we was done row wise this is
the column wise and and so think of it
this way each machine owns a certain
number of features and all all examples
but only keeps the features only keeps
the information for for those
features it all okay all right and now
what do you want to do you want each
machine independently to pick which cord
and is there going to update at each
iteration okay so and this is how nice
right so so you update to here to here
to here and each machine takes
independent updating these two and every
iteration did they pick which two they
can update all they can update one if
you want whatever you want but all of
them are they the same number so this is
how nice right so it was like this so
there is no central machine telling
these machines what they should pick
they pick it on their own but the
sampling as a set valued mapping is a
union of these independent on my
samplings okay right so now when you hit
this you have to come up with this eso
this ESO will be different it will lead
to different W different beta and that's
how you run your algorithm alright and
and this is what you can say so if you
have this setting where you have this
constant quadratic over approximation so
so recall L is just the diagonal and if
you if you make if you put ones on the
diagonal of ata
you get the Sigma small Sigma is good
then if you have s head with this
distributor nice sampling because that's
how you would run it and you have C
notes so these were three notes so you
have C notes each note owns and oversee
variables so we exactly the same number
of variables coordinates features then
you get ESO and these are the parameters
so you have to do some work to calculate
these parameters it turns out these WS
these weights here are just the diagonal
elements of a ta okay so no work to
compute those it's easy
what is the beta in this beta is
something that looks ugly right before
we had something that looked like this
instead of Sigma we had Omega instead of
tau we had this ratio of these
expectations and so on but there's this
additional term so alright so the Sigma
is the spectrum of the data thing of it
that way and this Sigma Sigma hat
depends on the partition
and the partitioning can be bet or it
could and this is a novel element in
this distributed setting so let's let's
look at this so this is the beta this is
the spectral norm of the partitioning in
some sense so I'm not telling you the
exact definition but it depends on the
data and depends on the partitioning if
partitioning is bad this is bad and this
term may create a very large beta which
is bad for the algorithm right the whole
talk is about this beta we want it to be
small all right well beta 1 beta 2
fortunately if tau is at least 2 which
of course if you have a distributed
algorithm on each no to update one
according at a time you don't update as
many as they could subject to
communication you know not being you
know too large too much right then beta
2 is at most beta 1
so essentially what it says the second
term doesn't matter at the cost of at
most doubling the number of iterations
how you partition doesn't matter so why
is this good news well it's good news
because then you can partition data in
such a way that you let's say minimize
the communication cause or something
like this and you don't have to worry
about the effect on the number of
iterations all right ok so this is what
you get number of iteration would be
something like this
2 times beta 1 and this is good because
if tau is large this would be about
Sigma if Sigma is small everything is
fine
divided by tau times C tau times C is
the number of coordinate updates in one
iteration of this distribute algorithm
because you update tau on each one of
these C machines ok so this is what you
would want so any questions
good so now I didn't talk about
communication how that is done and I
will not really talk about it because I
don't have the time for this but
essentially this is how you partition
the data matrix column wise you can do
you can you can have a reduce step if
you want you can have a what we call a
synchronous stream line where you
essentially send these things in a ring
these updates because they need to do
some communication so we have an
asynchronous implementation so none of
this matters I'll just focus on that
plot there we have an asynchronous
implementation of this where the
communication is done in such a way that
each node just send some information to
one neighbor and that's it and then new
iteration happens each node sends it to
a neighbor in the ring and then this
will happen in about this thousand
seconds out of 17 minutes or something
like this in 17 minutes you solve the
problem which which has which is of size
3 terabytes and by solving I mean 10 to
power 12 to 10 to the power minus 15 or
something less this is soft all right so
so you can stop much much earlier if you
want all right if you have a machine
learning application you would never
want to do this we wanted to make sure
you can actually solve a problem right
and this is the asynchronous
implementation stream line and this is
the reduce all where actually it's done
properly following the theory so if you
properly follow the theory then you get
this blue thing so it's a little bit
worse but it still works and this was
done with 512 MPI processes on 128 crane
machine on Hector shipping computer that
used to be the largest supercomputer in
the UK now second largest all right so
this thing works and this is how the
billion coordinates features and billion
examples all right so I'll conclude and
then then there is some extra time for
questions
so core innocent methods scare very well
to big data applications and problems
but have to be there
careful she'll be ed up the update
should we average them up you have to
look at the function at the structure of
the function to see what you should add
up the updates average or do something
in between you would like to add them up
and the structure is lots of structures
partial several really small spectral
norm of the data
néstor separable if that was the two
thing on the list which I didn't talk
about and now there's lots of lots of
work on coordinates and algorithms and
many many of the people in the field are
actually here or listening to us online
so shy shy Schwarz is here done some
amazing work and I think jeongja will be
speaking tomorrow about accelerated
parallel coordinates and algorithm with
a different set up even Esther were on
this on this and so on jashin lin xiao
etc is the shotgun paper so there's a
paper where we work with arbitrary
probabilities and this is the paper for
tomorrow advertisement for it thank you
very much could you could you say it
again I was just swallowing the water
sorry I was just swallowing the water
egg
I didn't hear just just say it again
could you repeat okay we're just kind of
hear each other no it's just drinking
water yeah of course all I described
here was was uniform but but you
completely right if you want to speed
things up you should do something to go
away from uniform and there's several
options I think I think there's other
grad with just something like this where
we try to do exactly what you suggested
or what you could do you could you could
sample proportionally to the Lipschitz
constants right which is completely okay
the theory goes through all right now
what you then get is is that the
dependence is done on the average of
these Lipschitz constants another thing
that you could do you could just sample
in such a way that you assign
probabilities to each subsets in an
optimal way so as to minimize the
complexity bound there's another way of
doing it yet another way of doing this
is to say I don't really know this
Lipschitz constants are in these
directions I adaptively change them as I
go because these these can be still and
what one can do that as well so there's
many ways in which you can go beyond
this theory to make this more practical
another way of doing this if you have a
lawsuit problem many many things become
zero very quickly if this l1 regularizer
has a large constant in front of it and
you just want to stop updating those
things so you can you can you can you
know do some engineering even though
it's harder to then analyze such an
algorithm but we do have the results in
one of these papers where you can get in
even five times or three four or five
times speed-up compared to this because
this is following the theory if you do
some tricks yeah
yes yes so there's two answers to the
first repeat the question I know whether
this is being recorded or you cut it
it's being recorded okay so it's
probably first talk when there's
questions being recorded okay
so so the question was that if you go
beyond n over Omega with number of
machines when you can still gain because
the theory would say that maybe you
might not gain something like this right
okay so so first of all this theory is
quite conservative because it tells you
it gives you this very general structure
for F partial separable Airy and it
doesn't look inside the function further
than that which means that Omega may be
proxy for something which is much
smaller than Omega and the true behavior
of the algorithm depends on the thing
that is much smaller and that's actually
there's the case as you've seen with
these Sigma's the Sigma's are some
eigenvalues etc and they can be much
smaller than this Omega Omega it's just
upper bound on this thing so one answer
to that will be would be yes the true
behavior would be would sometimes behave
with something else but that the bound
is tied so sometimes it doesn't
now if the bound is tight then you've
seen these examples where you just can't
win you add these things up and you any
kind of way but with this analysis with
this analysis I do not know whether
there is a different way of doing this
so maybe just completely different way
of thinking about the paralyzing core in
the same not in this matter I don't know
well but here is here is here is here is
another answer to your question another
answer is that actually the speed-up is
not really kept the speed-up still I
mean if you increase the number of
processors they're still speed-up it
just it just it just slows down to
almost a constant but it's still going
up the function is increasing or beta
divided by tau is decreasing with tau
okay but it's decreasing ever ever so
slowly yeah you're right at some point
it's almost it's almost no speeder yeah
so I know they'll be of course great but
that that's I don't know